NETO MARIN: Hey, I'm Neto.
And we are here for another
Behind the Actions episode.
And we have another guest today.
I invited one of our engineers
from the developer relations
team.
Say hello, Taylor.
TAYLOR CALDWELL:
Hey, how's it going?
NETO MARIN: What are
you doing on our team?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: So I'm an
engineer for Actions on Google.
I help build client libraries,
code samples, snippets,
basically anything that'll
help developers build actions
for the Google Assistant.
NETO MARIN: So when they
go to the GitHub repo
and find some cool
samples there,
you were one of the
responsible ones there?
If any people want to
open issues for you--
no, I'm kidding.
But yes, right?
You post code there,
create code labs, whatever.
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Yeah, any
code that is open source
on Actions on Google
GitHub, I've contributed to,
so if anyone has any issues
or questions about that,
they can reach out to us there.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
And then today, the idea is
to view the fulfillment code,
but using the Java
client library, right?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Right.
NETO MARIN: So for example, if
you remember the first episode,
with Jessica, we built the
lucky number calculator, using--
I used some machine learning--
very serious stuff--
to calculate that, and
we're going to use today.
Of course, it's just measuring
the length of the string.
But at that time,
we used Node.js.
It was our first client
library, and now we
have this Java code in
the client library, right?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Right.
NETO MARIN: So OK.
So let's build it
and see how it's
going to work with the
Java client library.
But, first, what is a
client library, Taylor?
How could we explain
to a person--
I'm starting with the Actions
on Google Development,
what is a client library?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Right, so a
client library is a library,
or a tool, that can help
developers more easily code
their apps.
So when you're building
for the Google Assistant,
a lot of the communication
back and forth is done in JSON.
And if you're using a language
that's object-oriented,
like Java, handling
JSON is not really--
it's not really easy to do.
NETO MARIN: You have a
lot of boilerplate code
to check the entities, the
kind of objects, right?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Right, right.
So providing a client library
allows you to take any data
and represent it as
an object in Java
so it's more easy to work with.
NETO MARIN: But
also it's important
because we are also giving some
tools to handle some specific--
for example, the intent
helpers or transactions,
they don't need to check
what's the correct name
of that permission.
We already are kind
of wrapping everything
on the client library, right?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Right.
So it wraps a lot
of functionality.
So we have a lot of
helpers when you're
building actions for
checking permissions,
confirmation, stuff like that.
And these are just converted
into simple methods in Java
that you can just call.
There's also some
annotations in Java
that allow you to mark
things as a intent handlers
so that you can specify
specific pieces of code
for each of your intents
that you're creating.
NETO MARIN: So it makes the
developer's life easier, right?
NETO MARIN: Right.
NETO MARIN: So
and just remember,
like we already said
in the first episode,
and I'm going to
say again, you can
use any language you prefer.
If you are coding Ruby,
Python, Rust, whatever, PHP,
there is no problem.
But we only have these two
client libraries right now.
Maybe when you are
watching this video,
we already have another one,
so check out our GitHub.
And, by the way, the
code is all there.
If someone wants to check how
we are coding-- how we are doing
the client library, or
even create a new client
library for another language
and want to use our code base,
they can check it out, right?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Yeah, so
all of our code samples
are open sourced on GitHub,
including the stuff that we're
going to be using today.
NETO MARIN: OK, just
wrapping up this part so
we can start to
code, because I think
people would start
shaking if they don't
see some code for a long time.
For example, the
client library want
to work like I can add these
as a dependency in our project.
So using IntelliJ or any
other IDE, Vim or something
like that, they could add
this as a library, right?
So it's on Maven?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Right,
so the client library
is available on Maven central,
so you can use basically
any Java IDE that you wish--
Eclipse, IntelliJ.
Today we will be using IntelliJ.
And the dependency will be
pulled from Maven central using
build scripts.
We'll be using Gradle for that.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
So let's start.
First, in terms of
the requirements, what
does the developer need in the
machine to run this library,
do the project, for example?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Right,
so as I mentioned before,
you'll first need an
IDE, and then you'll
need to check out
the code off GitHub.
Once you have the code, you
can import it into your IDE.
And then also, for
deployments, you--
depending on where you're
deploying your code--
NETO MARIN: Yeah, your
cloud provider or something
like that.
TAYLOR CALDWELL:
Your cloud provider.
So, today, we're going to
be using Google App Engine,
and to deploy, you'll need
a tool called the Cloud SDK.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
So if you need more information
about the Google App Engine,
please go to our
cloud.google.com.
There is a ton of tools there,
manuals that you can check.
We're going to use the Google
App Engine because it's
the easier way, in my opinion.
It's just a few
comments, and you
can deploy and have it working.
But if you have your
own cloud provider--
if you have your own
server, there's no problem.
Just remember the
Actions on Google
requires HTTPS connection--
an external connection.
So if you have only an
internal server or network,
you won't be able to because
the Google Assistant must
reach your web hook, right?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Right.
NETO MARIN: So then this
is one of the reasons why
we have the Google App Engine.
It fits perfectly
for this case, right?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Right.
NETO MARIN: So OK,
let's stop talking.
Can you please show us--
let's start with the
project creation.
TAYLOR CALDWELL: So if
you visit the console,
the Actions on Google
console, you can actually
create a project here.
And then you give
your project a name.
NETO MARIN: Let's put Java
Lucky Number Calculator,
just to make it different
from the previous ones
in the other episodes.
And I think most of
our viewers, they
are already kind of
familiar with this process.
So we won't make too
much comments about this.
If you have any
questions or doubts
about how to create
a project, please
go to our first Behind
the Actions episode,
where we go through all
the creation process,
explaining all the details
about all the fields.
But right now, let's
go straight through
to the intents creation.
So, now, I think
the first step is
to customize the welcome
intent, just the message, right?
Say, hello, tell me your
favorite color, right?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Right.
NETO MARIN: Just to make it
similar to the first episode we
had, we should, for example,
customize the welcome intent,
right?
And change the phrase,
the welcome, the response,
to something like--
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Hello,
what is your favorite color?
NETO MARIN: Yeah, I can remove
this and add a new response
like, what's your
favorite color?
For now, let's use just one.
But again, it's just
because we already
went through the process
of creating an action.
So now hit Save.
I think it's good, right?
But to handle the user answer,
we need another intent.
So Taylor is going to
create a new intent.
My job is easier today, right?
I'm just saying him
to do something,
because the idea is
to go straight forward
to the back-end
fulfillment development.
So favorite color-- great.
Add some phrase like, my
favorite color is orange,
purple, exactly.
Perfect.
So now we need to
enable the fulfillment.
So let's go to fulfillment,
enable fulfillment.
Perfect.
Save.
But if we go to the
fulfillment section,
for example, we don't have
the web hook yet, right?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Right,
so we need to set that up.
NETO MARIN: So let's
use the Java library.
How is the process--
for example,
if I'm starting
with development,
how is the process?
For example, I'm
just here and I want
to start right now
creating this project.
TAYLOR CALDWELL: So my
first recommendation
would be to download an IDE.
I have an IDE
pre-installed, IntelliJ.
Once you have your text editor,
you can go to the Actions
on Google GitHub and view all
of our open source projects.
There you will find
the boilerplate project
for the Java client library.
NETO MARIN: So this is very
cool because we already
created some classes and code.
So you can start your
project without--
for example, it's
not from scratch.
We already have
created some structure
compatible with
Google App Engine,
and also we created
an AWS handler.
But, in this case, you're
going to delete this handler
because you only need the Google
App Engine handler, right?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Right.
NETO MARIN: So you can download
here or from command line,
whatever you prefer.
TAYLOR CALDWELL: So if
you visit the GitHub,
you can clone the project.
Let's see.
I'm going to make a directory
called Java library demo.
And then we can
clone the project.
Perfect.
NETO MARIN: So what
is happening now?
If you're not familiar
with this GitHub,
we are downloading the
code from the GitHub.
This code was created by Taylor
and the rest of the team,
so it'll help you a lot.
So what is the
structure here, Taylor?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: So once
you check out the code,
you can actually open
it in your text editor.
It'll be easier to view the
structure of the code there.
NETO MARIN: How we
can open this there.
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Yeah,
so if you open IntelliJ,
you can import the project by
clicking the Import Project
button and navigating
to the clone directory
and selecting the
build.gradle file.
NETO MARIN: Oh yes.
In this case, you
are using Gradle,
so it's easier to do
all day build tasks.
But if you are using
Maven, you also
can use your own architectures.
But in this case
already it's ready.
You can just open the
IntelliJ and import.
And it's very cool because
already the dependencies,
the wrapper is there.
TAYLOR CALDWELL:
Right, so Gradle
will handle all of
the dependencies
that the project uses.
It will compile your project,
build all the class files,
and then yeah.
So if you don't have Gradle
installed on your machine,
you can actually use
the Gradle wrapper
that's packaged with IntelliJ.
NETO MARIN: Yeah,
this is a good point.
For example, if you are new to
the Gradle world or something
like that and don't know
how to use on your machine,
you can also start from
our code that we always
wrap the compatible
version of the code.
So it's ready?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Yeah.
So, as soon as you
import the project,
you'll see that
everything builds.
NETO MARIN: OK.
Can you comment about
this structure here,
about what classes we have
here and how they're organized?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Yeah, sure.
So, if you look at
the source code,
and you go to the main folder,
you'll see a couple classes.
One of the classes
is ActionsServlet.
This is an entry point
into your back end.
So when you deploy your projects
or your fulfillment code,
any requests and responses
will go through this class,
this server class.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
And this class, for
example, the developers,
they don't need to
customize this class, right?
Because you're already doing
all the work for them, right?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Right.
So the boilerplate, we provide
two different entry points.
We provide one that's just
a basic servlet, which
is really common in Java.
And then we also provide
one for AWS Lambda.
Because the request and
response that come in
is a tad different, you have
to handle them differently.
NETO MARIN: So you can remove
the other handler in this case,
right?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Yeah, so,
since we're not using AWS,
we can completely
delete this class.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
But now I see
another class here.
So where should I--
for example, because on
the Node.js client library,
I have to create a
function and then I
have a function for
intent, and then,
of course, one of
the methodologies.
But you have one
method for intent.
We have something similar
for the Java client library?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Yeah, so if
you look at the second class
that we have here, we have
this MyActionsApp class.
This is equivalent to the app
instance in Node.js client
library.
NETO MARIN: It's where
the magic happens, right?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Yeah, this is
where all the magic happens.
So this is where you define
any code for handling
any of your intents.
And depending on if you're
using Dialogflow or Actions
SDK, you can, instead of using
the constructor like you would
in Node.js of instantiating
an instance of Dialogflow
App or Actions SDK App, you
extend the class's Dialogflow
or Actions SDK App.
NETO MARIN: OK, cool.
So we have a bunch of
boilerplate also, like welcome.
But we are not using
the fulfillment
to reply to the welcome intent.
We are handling all
from Dialogflow.
In this case, we can for
example remove this, right?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Yeah.
So we created a project
on our own in Dialogflow.
So we can remove any
intent handlers here.
We can actually reuse this
default welcome intent one
because it's just a
basic welcome intent.
NETO MARIN: Remember to
check the intent name,
so have the same
name in the notation.
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Right.
So the annotation should
match the intent name
that was defined in Dialogflow.
So if we go back to our
project in Dialogflow,
we'll see that our
default welcome intent is
named Default Welcome Intent.
And looking back at our code, we
have the default welcome intent
annotation for
this block of code.
NETO MARIN: Yeah but in this
case, we won't use this one.
We'll just reuse the
code, and then they
must match the favorite color.
TAYLOR CALDWELL: So
because our default
welcome intent doesn't
reach out to fulfillment,
we do not need this one.
We can go ahead and go to
our favorite color intent
and change it to
handle this intent.
So to do that, we can
change the annotation
to be Favorite Color.
NETO MARIN: And how do I
know the color the user said?
Because on Node.js, for
example, I have the parameter
after the conversation object.
And here we are sending
also a parameter, right?
Can you go back?
Yeah, so you go the Actions and
parameters, we have the color.
How do we handle this parameter
in the Java client library?
TAYLOR CALDWELL:
So this parameter
is passed in to
your Java back end.
And to actually access
these parameters,
you would use a Get Parameter
method on the request.
NETO MARIN: So I don't
need-- for example,
if I have a bunch
of parameters, I
don't need to keep changing
the method's signature.
For example, it
allows me-- maybe
if I'm sending new parameters,
it won't break my code.
Like, OK, I'm adding
these parameters,
that I'm going to use
maybe in another moment,
and it won't bring the code.
So I can keep using the same.
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: Cool.
So show us all the AI stuff
that you do on the color string
and return the lucky number.
TAYLOR CALDWELL: OK, sure.
So just looking at
the method body of--
let me actually delete this.
So first when you create
an intent handler,
you'll need a response builder
to build your response.
So we declare that.
Next, we'll want to grab the
color that the user said.
And to do that, you can
actually do request.getParameter
and then specify the name of
the parameter that you want.
So here we named it color.
So back in our code, we can say
we want the color parameter.
And all parameters come
back in Java as objects,
so you'll have to cast
them to a string--
in this case, it
will be a string.
So we can say color
is equal to string.
NETO MARIN: Now the
machine learning--
TAYLOR CALDWELL: And now
the machine learning code.
So--
NETO MARIN: Is this calculated
out on the blockchain?
No, I'm kidding.
I like these buzzwords.
Maybe we can get more
viewers with these buzzwords.
TAYLOR CALDWELL: So we're
going to use machine
learning to generate a number.
So to do that,
we'll get the color,
and we'll get the
length of the color.
And then we'll actually multiply
it by just a special number.
NETO MARIN: 1, 2, 3--
this is a very special number.
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Very special.
And then, once we
have that number,
we can actually
return it to the user.
NETO MARIN: OK, and we also
add what the assistant is going
to say, so your lucky number--
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Right.
So for our response, we'll want
to have some kind of prompt
to the user.
So in this case, we can
say, your lucky number
is, and then the number
that we got back.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
TAYLOR CALDWELL: And then,
to add that to the response,
we'll use our response builder
and then use the Add method
to add that string
as a response.
And then if we want to end
the conversation in Java,
the equivalent in Node is--
so you have .close.
In Java, to end
the conversation,
you can call .endConversation
on the end of your response
builder.
NETO MARIN: And this is
a very interesting point
that, when we were planning
the API, designing the API,
remember some discussions
about the math names.
And we had some
people say, hey, maybe
the math names should
match the Node.js.
And actually, we kind of
think different because we
are writing a very
Java idiomatic library.
So if you already use
standard Java and Kotlin--
and by the way, this library
is developed from Kotlin,
so the library is--
the code is in Kotlin.
So if you are used to the
Java idiomatic, the syntax,
you'd be very familiar
with the APIs we created.
But probably you
see some differences
if you're migrating from
the Node.js to the Java.
Maybe, like you said,
instead of .close,
it would be like
endConversation.
But good to frame it.
I think it's important.
TAYLOR CALDWELL: So once
you are ready to deploy,
you can actually open the
terminal up in IntelliJ.
To do that, you can go to
View, Tool Windows, Terminal.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
And it's cool because
you're already
in your project, your class
path, and everything else,
so you don't need to like check
if you're on the right path,
right?
NETO MARIN: Right.
So it automatically detects
where the project path is.
You don't have a separate
terminal window open and like
cd into that directory.
So when you're ready
to deploy, you'll
need to use the
Cloud SDK tool that I
mentioned earlier before.
We have it pre-installed
on this machine right now.
And to use it you can say gcloud
init to initialize you project.
From there, it will ask you
to initialize a project,
and you can say, create
new configuration,
and give it some kind of name.
And then log in with your email.
So after you configure
your project,
you will want to actually
deploy the application.
You can do that
from the terminal,
or IntelliJ also provides--
NETO MARIN: A short cut?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: It provides
a shortcut in the Gradle tab.
So in the boilerplate
that we provide,
we have a bunch of
Gradle tasks for--
NETO MARIN: Let me guess.
One is to the Google
App Engine task.
TAYLOR CALDWELL:
Yeah, so we have
one for deploying to
Google App Engine.
So if you go to the
Gradle tab in IntelliJ--
NETO MARIN: This is
why we hired you.
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Yeah, you
can go to Tasks, App Engine,
and then there's
App Engine Deploy.
So if you double click that--
NETO MARIN: Now it's
the moment, you know?
TAYLOR CALDWELL:
The dancing moment?
NETO MARIN: Let's
see if it's working.
TAYLOR CALDWELL:
The deploy dance?
NETO MARIN: Let's see.
You only have the right
to do the deploy dance
if you deploy it.
So let's see.
It's working.
Now, what is happening is
it is creating the instance
because the Google App Engine
is like a platform as a service.
So it's uploading all the
code to create a new instance.
In general, the
first time you run,
it's kind of more slowly
than the other times, right?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Yes.
So initially it'll
be a little slow.
It'll take around a few seconds.
And then once it's
deployed, any follow up
deployments will
be a lot quicker.
NETO MARIN: OK, finish--
it's deployed!
We can check.
Can you check the endpoint?
Is this the endpoint?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Yeah,
so this is the endpoints.
So our endpoint
right now is only
responding to POST
requests actually.
NETO MARIN: So with this URL,
you can now fill the web hook.
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Yeah,
so using this URL,
we can actually set
up our fulfillments
by providing a Dialogflow.
NETO MARIN: Great, so nice.
So we can save here?
But there is one-- just before
we do the deploy action there
and do the test with our
credible Google Home Hub,
we must configure at least
the name of the action, right?
Because I think we
are using my test app,
something that is very common.
People, when they're
doing their first project,
they're doing like
with my test app.
You can go in the Actions
in Google console--
and just remember
for invocation,
let's change your
Java lucky number,
just to make sure that we are
invoking the right action,
so people say we
are not shoddy here.
They're not using a free--
like, we made the homework and
have some working code before.
Now it's time to integrate,
deploy to the Google
Hub to test and test, right?
Well, it's deployed, as
we see on your screen.
We are seeing the simulator.
We won't test in the simulator.
Let's test on the
Home Hub, and I
will judge if you are allowed
to do our deploy dance when
it works.
So, hey Google, talk
to Java Lucky Number.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK.
Let's get the test version
of Java Lucky Number.
Hey, what's your favorite color?
NETO MARIN: Orange.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Your
lucky number is 738.
NETO MARIN: Woo!
It's working!
Yeah, I like this.
So what happened here?
So we w test from
your App Engine,
you deployed, we copied the
URL, set up the fulfillment,
and it can work.
It's working right?
OK, maybe it's kind
of very simple.
But this is an idea to
showcase how you can--
the pieces you have to connect.
But for example, just remember
all the features are available.
Everything we have on the
platform is already available.
So rich response.
What else?
TAYLOR CALDWELL:
Yeah, rich responses.
So you have things like your
basic cards, your carousels.
Anything that is available
in the Node client library
will be available in
the Java client library.
NETO MARIN: And if they want
to check something right now
and see how to use these
advanced features, where
they should go?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: So if
you want to check out
any advanced features
of our platform,
you can always check out
our developer documentation.
NETO MARIN: And
also some samples--
TAYLOR CALDWELL:
And also, yeah, we
have code samples that
outline things like updates,
push notifications,
transactions, conversation
components.
NETO MARIN: Nice, nice.
This is great.
So again, we
demonstrated here how
to use the Google App Engine
and the Java client library
using IntelliJ.
But if you're using
Kotlin and Eclipse,
and deploying to
another cloud provider
tree or own infrastructure,
it's totally up to you.
We are only providing the client
library and the boilerplate
code to save you some time.
Well, I think we kind of
covered the basic stuff
around the client library,
so any other thing we
would like to mention
to developers about it?
TAYLOR CALDWELL: Yeah, sure.
So our client library
is written in Kotlin.
This allows you to--
it provides interoperability
when you're coding,
so you can either call
Java code or Kotlin code
while you're developing
your actions.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, and they
can find those on Twitter.
Our team handle is
@ActionsOnGoogle.
Also our Twitter handle--
it's fun to talk with us.
All the information will be
on the video description,
so you can find our Twitter.
And also remember,
if you're posting
something cool or did something
cool or have any comment
about this, please use the
#aogdevs hashtag on Twitter.
We can see that.
And also we are on
a new platform now.
We have a section on Reddit,
and also a Stack Overflow.
Our team is always checking
Stack Overflow and Reddit
to answer our questions.
So OK.
Thank you, Taylor,
for being here.
It was great.
And, remember, if
you have any other--
want to see any other advanced
thing or different thing,
check our GitHub,
github.com/actionsongoogle.
There are plenty of samples
using the Java client
library and everything.
Thanks for watching.
See you next time.